Here's everything I eat in a day.
As someone that loves to cook
but is also 30 weeks pregnant,
I hate the taste of water
so I always need to add stuff to it.
Today it was cucumber and mint.
I also wake up craving fresh orange juice everyday.
So today I made a grapefruit orange juice.
Got started on making some wild blueberry compote
to go alongside my cassava flour waffles.
These are so easy to make
and they always turn out so crispy
but chewy in the middle.
They're my favorite thing,
so I ended up having two of those
with my blueberry compote.
So good! And then for a midday beverage,
you guys know I always need to have one.
I made a vanilla blueberry iced tea,
started on making some lunch,
and chopped up some green onions and lemongrass
to go inside my Vietnamese pork lemongrass meatballs.
I seared those off
and then got started on making my vermicelli salad.
I Julian some carrots and some cucumber,
made a nok chom dressing,
and then assembled it all with some fresh herbs.
Don't forget the mint,
my meatballs,
the noodles!
This was so refreshing
but feeling at the same time
in the afternoon.
Needed a little sweet pick me up. So
I made a lime whipped cream to go inside of my papaya.
Dinner was something easy and quick
so made a roast chicken.
I spatchcock my chicken
and then made a little gochujang marinade to go
All over it.
Love a roast chicken
because you can just make it pop in the oven
and forget about it for a few hours.
And I cut up some root vegetables,
toss them in the leftover marinade,
and then laid my chicken
on top of some onion and garlic.
I added some chicken stock to my cast iron
and put that in the oven.
That was almost done.
I made a garlic yuzu spinach,
and then I pulled out my beautiful chicken,
carved myself up a piece,
and that was my dinner.
I love something comforting to end my day.